It's go time.
Day one.
I'm excited to be back.
Back at the TVA.
Everything is stepped up again.
The stakes are huge.
You get to see Tom in a suit.
A lot of people are going to like that.
We introduced this whole new corner
to the MCU and these new characters.
I've been a fan of the Marvel Universe
for a long time.
I'm so grateful to be a part of this
amazing series.
Rest assured,
our Loki will be with our Mobius
and they will be dealing with
the consequences of this first season.
Over the top, don't you think?
I thought it was spot on.
Season two is about Loki understanding
himself.
Loki has always been a villain.
What we want to explore is also Loki
finding what heroism really looks like.
We're playing God.
We are gods.
He's found a new family.
There's a new capacity
to make connections.
What is it that you really want?
I want to save my friends.
He realizes that those connections
are all that matter.
In the end.
The amazing Loki.
Everyone.
He'll be here all week.
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
This will be my new Loki Season 2
trailer video.
They've just released
a whole bunch more footage,
and they just upped the premiere dates.
We're getting episodes earlier every week,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
Cannot wait to see how Loki is going
to destroy the multiverse even faster.
Like you can't give all the credit
to destroying everything to Deadpool,
even though Deadpool three
is supposed to directly set up Avengers
secret wars and they're supposed to happen
after the last incursions happen.
You have questions?
Yes, I had a lot of questions.
I'm sure you had a lot of questions.
But rest assured,
we're going to answer them right now.
The funny thing about all this is like,
you know, we are hopeful that Loki is able
to save his friends like he's
trying to stop time from literally coming
unraveled at the seams
as it looks like in the trailers.
but we all know about Avengers 5 Kang
Dynasty, Avengers six Secret wars.
Like we know that everything eventually
is going to collapse on itself.
the fun is going to be watching them
all scramble, trying to save things
while it just continues to get worse
and worse and worse.
the big news for episodes, though,
is that they have the premiere date
and they're doing the same thing
they did for Asoka episodes.
So instead of releasing Loki season
two episodes at midnight,
now they're releasing episodes at 6 p.m.
Thursdays Pacific Time.
So just convert that to whichever
time zone you live in.
my episode videos for
that will post early Friday mornings.
It'll be just like the way
the Asoka episodes work.
I post those like the morning
after Ahsoka episodes come out.
my guess is that Disney just realized
that they got way better viewership
numbers on those episodes
by releasing them at 6 p.m.
Pacific time
instead of releasing them at midnight.
look.
Even though they're a bunch of hardcore
fans out there, myself
included, who watch stuff at like,
I'll stay up to watch stuff at midnight
because I do videos
for a lot of this stuff.
most regular people
tend to watch television
when they're awake during normal hours.
my only guess is that
they'll just continue doing this for
like all their Future
series, that release on a weekly basis.
the only big difference between episodes
and Loki episodes
is there's only going to be six
episodes of Loki Season two,
but they did six episodes
during season one.
Marvel has this weird kick
where they just do six episodes sometimes
or the two super short episodes,
and they'll do nine of them.
They're supposed to be changing that
with Daredevil Born Again.
When that releases,
there'll be eight episodes for season one,
but they'll have like a midseason break,
like traditional TV.
Like you remember old television,
like the Arrowverse
shows would have a bunch of episodes,
but they'd have a little break
between the middle.
Maybe if we're lucky,
Marvel will start doing that.
Like they'll do stronger series images,
do more episodes of those stronger series.
also love the way they use missed minutes
to make some of these announcements too
like she's super sinister
because we know what's going on
with the character as opposed to season
one when they were a little more coy
about revealing that
like she's telling you,
you better watch the episodes earlier
or else Just watch.
Generally, it feels like what Marvel
has done behind the scenes with the Loki
character is just make him
a way more central figure
in this saga of Marvel movies
like Phase four, Phase five, and Phase six
through Avengers Secret Wars.
Like, there's
basically three phases to each saga.
The last big one was the Infinity saga.
This time, though, it's because of the way
everything is working
with the council of kangs
being behind everything,
the incursions, the way the TVA works,
Loki's pretty much at the center
of everything that's happening, in.
He's almost solely responsible for
a lot of the stuff that's happening now.
They're like a lot of other people
that are messing up big time,
like Deadpool is going to mess up
big time, destroying more universes.
Sylvie is technically
the person who killed he who remains Dr.
Strange is causing all kinds of incursions
all across the multiverse.
I think there are a bunch of big
Marvel characters
that are slowly destroying all of reality
as quickly as possible.
But it does feel like Loki has a front row
seat to everything that's happening
Kevin Feige.
He also did confirmed that it was Sylvie
killing he who remains during Loki season
one that set off this whole arc of Marvel
with the multiverse,
the Council of Kangs being that new
Thanos level threat, so to speak.
Technically, there'll be a different Kang
variant during secret wars,
but he's still meant to be a former member
of the Council of Kangs.
so the whole concept is that a
king is going to be the replacement
for this overarching
Thanos type of villain in this saga.
now because we know they're going
to be rolling really hard on an X-Men saga
like X-Men centric Saga.
After Secret Wars,
everybody's going to be wondering who's
going to be their overarching X-Men
specific type of deal,
like who is the Thanos replacement,
but from the X-Men comics,
We're also supposed to see a bunch of Loki
crossover in Deadpool three,
The TVA will be main
characters in the movie.
Maybe there'll be a Loki cameo.
Supposedly
they film some Loki stuff for that movie.
maybe.
If we're lucky, we'll get some Deadpool
Easter eggs during Loki Season two.
It feels like they do have
like a completely separate plot,
so maybe there's just like a post-credits
scene
in the finale teasing Deadpool's stuff.
they also recently screened
like the first 5 minutes of Loki season
two episode one,
and apparently it picks up immediately
in this moment from the end of the season
one finale
with Loki trying to explain who he is,
what happened during season one,
In apparently the real reason why
Mobius and Hunter B-15 don't have any idea
what's going on with him.
Recognize him is because
when Sylvie sent him back to the TVA,
he didn't wind up in an alternate reality
like we all thought at the time.
apparently he was pushed back in time
to the beginning of the TVA's existence
and is going to be part of the time
slipping plot
that they teased in all the previous
trailers.
basically, Loki is jumping backwards
and forwards within his own timeline
within the TVA.
so the whole idea is that Loki in Sylvie
were at the end of time, like literally
the very end of time
before the universe collapsed in his own
he death when they were with
he who remains in the season one finale.
So essentially Loki overshot
his destination when he was trying
to travel back to the present day
that he left from And during this time
period, like when the TVA has just begun,
this Kang statue
that we saw in the finale is apparently
still he who remains version of Kang.
But apparently
when he first created the TVA,
he wasn't hiding his identity
from all the agents like he is.
Later in the timeline
The reason why Mobius and Hunter B-15
were here since the beginning of the TVA.
Even though it's existed
for millions of years,
is just because of the way
he remains, messes with time.
remember during Loki season one,
Mobius told Loki
that he didn't have any idea
of how long he'd been here.
Like, time kind of works a little bit
differently inside of the TVA.
So even though he originally came
from the nineties,
they're all meant to be variants.
Like all the TVA agents are variants.
So something happened.
He caused a Nexus event
back in the nineties. hee.
Who remains, pulls him out
to prevent the Nexus event from happening.
He becomes a TVA agent,
but he just plants him back
at the beginning of the TVA's existence.
during the beginning of episode one,
you have Loki here,
then going on the run, trying to escape
because everybody tries
to arrest him like a normal
very because they don't know who he is.
there's a quick speedrun version of what
we saw during season one episode one
when they first arrested him.
He has to like re explain everything
like you don't understand
in while that's going on
he continues to times
slip forwards and backwards
through his own timeline inside the TVA.
Some of these trailer shots are
from his distant future inside the TVA.
Some are from his distant past.
In the TVA.
based on all the other trailer footage.
They try to get help from K,
who he can help with the time slipping.
His name is Aura Boras.
They call him Obi for short.
the funny thing about that is that Aura
borrows also translates to time eater.
basically he's
meant to be the tech guy for the TVA.
He's supposed to have created
all of the TVA's Tech,
so he's like second only to Kang
in his ability to engineer tech like this,
this is them in one of the control rooms.
Looking at the timeline
that's coming on for like literally time
itself is coming unravel
and they have to figure out how to fix it.
it looks like they have a couple of site
adventures,
hunting down regular variants, doing what
the TVA would normally be doing,
what all this stuff is going on
in the background.
And during one of their missions
they go after the victor
timely variant of Kang,
bringing him back to the TVA.
Like this scene looks like him helping
them in the TVA with their problem.
supposedly
Jonathan Majors is going to be in
at least like four episodes,
maybe a couple different variants of King.
I don't think he's only going to show up
as the victor timely.
Kang I think there'll be
other variants of Kang
but I think this is a scene of them
bringing Victor timely.
Kang back to Aura borrows here
Kahui Quan's character and him
just going crazy, seeing like,
Oh wow, it's you.
So I think this is just meant to play into
the idea
that even though the Council of Kangs are
evil, want to get rid
of all the normal characters
messing with the multiverse
like the 616 Avengers characters,
pretty much anybody else
in the multiverse.
not all the Kang
variants are evil like this, Doctor.
Timely Kang
will help them try to fix time.
it also seems like
the beginning of the season is mostly them
just figuring out how to stop the time
slipping and getting Sylvie back on board
with the team.
Looking at some of the other trailer
footage, though,
this is the TVA's mail truck
that Loki is in.
zoom. An enhanced look,
the little bumper sticker with Ms.
minutes on here, too,
like saying to direct all complaints.
I think there's a really long string
of characters and numbers.
Marvel's actually started
selling merchandise like this
in real life, like Miss Minutes
merchandise all over the place.
K Hui Quan talks about coming to the MCU.
The the funny story
about how he wound up in Loki season two
is that after everything
everywhere, all at once,
came out the very first person
anywhere that called him was Kevin Foggy.
He was like,
You were amazing in this movie.
Please come be part of one of our Marvel
productions in Loki.
Season two just happened to be that thing
that they decided on him doing the other
big thing in this is Tom Hiddleston
talks about the events of season two
thinking that Mobius,
the others are his legitimate friends
now, like Loki does
have a traditional friend group
the way that he didn't have before,
kind of the same way
that 616 Loki got really close to Thor
before he was killed by Thanos
during Avengers Infinity War.
that's kind of the slippery slope
like the character
does something really awesome,
gets this awesome friend group,
but then they pull the rug out
from under them.
Something really terrible happens.
We know that in the MCU
now that's going to be Avengers 5 Kang
Dynasty, the Council of Kangs in Avengers
six Secret Wars.
right.
As Loki saves all of his friends, boom,
the rest of the multiverse
collapses on itself.
have a brand new scene of Loki
talking to Sylvie at this bar.
It looks like it happens when he finds her
working at that 1980s McDonald's
and they're still in the 1980s here.
She just hasn't returned yet.
He's wearing the same outfit
in all those scenes
and she just changed out of her McDonald's
uniform Speaking of all this Loki
McDonald's crossover,
I don't know if they're still selling
the Loki themed special sauce.
I guess basically the regular McDonald's
source just with Loki rapping on it.
So let me know
if you can still go to McDonald's
and actually buy that for a little while.
They actually converted a Brooklyn
McDonald's to look just like
the one in the Loki series
with like 1980 prices in designs.
But that was only for like a little while,
they'll probably another trailer or two
before this comes out.
We'll get a little bit more footage.
So of course I'll do more bonus videos
as we get closer to episode one.
But big reminder
that all my episode videos
will start posting after
they start releasing episodes.
My Ahsoka Episode
6 video we'll post Wednesday morning.
There's a bunch of other big stuff
coming up this week,
so be sure to enable alerts
so you don't miss anything.
Click here for that. Asoka episode video.
I think the link as soon as I post that
and click here for that brand new Deadpool
3 teaser trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!